[Music]
well welcome back to another episode of
the addie hour i'm honored today to be
able to host a conversation about
oxytocin and social behavior community
and mental health and a lot of ways
these topics have come up in a lot of
our conversations on this podcast
already but we really haven't been able
to dig into the science of social
behavior and community so today i'm
honored to be able to host
two
revered scientists a revered scientist
and philosopher
and luminaries in this in this area to
really engage in this conversation
so the first guest i'd like to introduce
is dr larry young
larry is a director of the center for
translational social neuroscience and
the director of the silvio o'conti
center for oxytocin and social cognition
at emory university in atlanta he's also
the william p timmy professor of
psychiatry at the emory school of
medicine and he leads the center for
social network
neural networks at the university of
scuba in japan so quite a few different
leadership roles he's someone who's
also been a recipient of numerous awards
including the golden brain award the
frank beach award the acmp daniel h
efron award and he's a fellow in the
american academy of arts and sciences
his research focuses on the
neurobiological mechanisms underlying
social relationships and how we can
translate some of that into treatments
for psychiatric illnesses with social
deficits such as autism
he's someone that i had the pleasure of
interacting with over the years as a
fellow neuroscientist he's actually
hosted me at his institution and served
in some mentoring roles as well which
i'm really grateful for so today i'm
honored to be able to welcome him here
to the addie hour podcast thanks for
being here larry thank you for inviting
me it's wonderful thank you
the second guest which i'd like to
introduce is dr patricia smith churchlin
who is a professor emeritus of
philosophy at the university of
california san diego and also an adjunct
professor at the salk institute
she is someone who has been a pioneer in
several different ways specifically her
work focuses on discoveries and
neuroscience and how that impacts
traditional philosophical ideas
she's the author of several books one
the pioneering book neurophilosophy but
also the book computation computational
brain also brain trust what neuroscience
tells us about morality touching the
nerve
conscience the origins of moral
intuition and she has been a uh
just a celebrated speaker over the years
as well having had listened to some of
her recent and uh talks from a few years
back i've been really impressed with the
way that she really has brought this
neurophilosophy to the forefront she's
someone who's been the past president of
the american philosophical association
and the society of philosophy and
psychology she won a macarthur prize in
1991 a rossi prize for neuroscience in
2008 and a prose prize
for science for her book brain trust so
someone again as i mentioned who's very
celebrated has also was also a previous
uh philosophy department chair at the
university of california san diego so
i'm honored to be able to welcome pat
churchlin to the adiaba podcast as well
thanks for being here
thanks so much for having me it's really
a great pleasure
well i'm grateful to both of you for the
work that you do and again this i think
is a conversation that's been a long
time coming on this podcast as these
topics and your names have actually come
up on previous episodes so full circle
for us in a lot of ways
but as my listeners know i often just
like to start out and check in with how
people are doing both of you as we can
hear from your cvs have very active
lives and so i'm curious to know how
you're both doing in this moment and
also what occupies you in your time on a
daily basis so pat actually if we could
start with you that'd be great
well i'm doing very well actually but
you know i'm retired and um so
you know i i
can do what i want with my days and i i
find that to be an absolutely amazing
experience
so i i do a lot of reading of course um
but i also walk the dog a lot and
i do about an hour of yoga every day and
meet up with my friends for drinks in
the afternoon and like that i also watch
some football
wow so a full a full plate i mean that's
encouraging to hear how
active you are you said you're retired
but you sound still very active in a lot
of ways which is excellent lots of ways
yeah well you know at a certain point of
course your body will tell you uh you're
done and it hasn't told me that yet so
i'm still you know i'm still going
excellent excellent
larry what about you
yeah things are going real well with us
here we're able to uh you know
work in the lab and come to work every
day and see people you know there was a
time when we didn't get to do that and i
that really was uh
strange and
you know i didn't like that very much
but uh you know so far we've been able
to adjust pretty well
during the pandemic i decided to
really try to get healthy and i started
exercising so now every day i sort of
start my day off with an exercise
routine and
come into work and
just try to you know get as much social
interaction as i can one thing i do miss
though is being able to travel as much
as i used to be able to
really meeting other
other scientists face to face uh that's
so important and we've just been missing
that for a long time now
yeah yeah
yeah i find that too i mean i find that
zoom
works quite well
when you're talking to people you
already know
but if
like i'm going to be giving a zoom talk
to folks in saudi arabia and i would so
much rather be there
and uh and then have a chance to
interact with them and talk about the
the
the work and so forth and and so that is
disappointing but but really in the long
haul of life it's not something i can
complain about right right but just that
opportunity that we had before to i mean
in a sense experience the culture in a
different way than you would absolutely
on the computer yeah yeah so that makes
a lot of sense i know we're going to get
to the social behavior piece eventually
but it's just you know as i'm listening
to both of you talk and thinking about
your areas of research and as you're
sharing about the losses of having those
connections i think a lot of things are
full circle in some ways although i will
start with a question in a sense
for both of you do you think you know
even as people who study
social behavior did it catch you off
guard at all how much
we've missed those rhythms or how it's
affected us or would you say that was
completely expected
i don't know um
i think people do vary
um both as a function of temperament and
as a function of age and what kinds of
routines and skills and so forth they
have
in how much the the isolation has has
affected them it affects everybody to to
some degree of course
but
um it it's clear that some people are
much more deeply bothered um
by it than others and i'm not quite sure
scientifically what that's what that
tells us right right
yeah i agree i think that there are some
people who
well they maybe they they at first they
feel they're thriving by you know being
at home and maybe they're introverted
they don't somehow yeah social
interactions are
a little bit uh
give them anxiety and
uh but then i think that you know by
completely avoiding those social
interactions but even when we have the
opportunity now
um you know i think that's really doing
some maybe some damage to their syria to
their mental health
yeah especially if they continue to
avoid the the social interactions that
because they really are healthy yeah
yeah although it's funny you know i i
was reflecting on on all of this and
thinking about you know i grew up in the
in this very remote area of british
columbia and
there were lots of people uh
who would be off prospecting in the
mountains for months and months on end
maybe not even a dog
and then there were the fur trappers a
little bit further north who would be
out in the in in the bush all winter
traffic and then they would come in in
the spring with their furs and they'd
whoop it up a little bit and back they'd
go and
i was you know it made me wonder is it
perhaps
the expectation of sociality and then
not getting it
that we find particularly painful
because i mean these old prospectors and
fur trappers they
well their social skills weren't
terrific as you may imagine and of
course you know they certainly needed a
bath
but
but
on the other hand they did not seem to
have
suffered mentally as a result of being
on their own for so long and i i mean
it was just part of life then but now i
look back on it like how did those guys
do that yeah
well yeah i think certainly there's
individual variation and how you know we
how much we need social interactions
but i think for for young people it's
especially important because they're
still at developing
i mean i mean students and graduate
students and people in the early phases
of their career i think it's the social
interactions is so
important for building the networks that
help them
succeed those trappers maybe they were
already fixed in their ways and all they
needed to do was trap
um where
yeah so but building that social skills
because you know things are going to
change again in two three four years
oh yeah our livelihood
is going to you know require
social interactions and social skills
yeah and i'm just afraid that some
people are not are you know they're
missing out on the normal development of
those skills yeah
yeah yeah i think those are really
important points i'm intrigued about
that you know not there's a clear answer
but the expectation component too and
how that plays into it so i mean you
could just hear that in the the public
discourse and how much
angst there seemed to be around the
expectation to be together and the
inability to be able to do that yeah you
have to facilitate it through other
means and then later to your point i
mean all the developmental components i
mean there's obviously an intersection
there as well i know that's something
that people will try and look at down
the road it's definitely an interesting
question
uh that will have
long-term impacts i mean just
development like thinking about how i
mean even if we think about younger you
know kids preschool and elementary
school what impact this is going to have
down the road for their social
development even those kids that going
to school uh and they have they went for
a couple of years yeah not seeing the
faces of other kids yeah yeah yeah the
facial expression you know we learn from
those real social interactions so it's
huge you know
rewiring that happens to help us learn
you know what other people are thinking
reading emotions and they're missing
that and i think it's really kind of
opened up a whole new
field of study for the next decade or so
you know it was um you know what what is
has been the impact of this right the
other thing that's changing things so
much is you know with the code came this
zoom and the ability to interact so
easily
over zoom
and uh you know that's sort of really
taking the place of a lot of
regular social interactions and you know
what are the consequences of that you
know and also dating
people have had a hard time dating right
it's really and now so in a couple for a
couple of years people had you know have
to date in a different way and so
that can have a long lasting impact as
well you know yeah
yeah
so much to process and think about i
definitely want to come back to that but
even as we you know we already touched
on so many topics about development and
the social interactions as well i want
to just take a step back and have you
all actually take us through the science
and philosophy of the social body and
social relationships because i know some
in our audience are familiar with that
some are vaguely familiar with it i've
heard about oxytocin a little bit or
i've heard about you know the love
hormone that's people sometimes
mystery make it out to be
over simplistic yes but in a sense just
want to kind of start there and and have
you share what we know both from your
own research and your own thinking and
from the field as well so um larry can
you take us through a little bit of the
biology of
what we know at this point yeah well let
me first start say something about
oxytocin since you mentioned that and
because this is a really uh important
molecule for social interactions and it
was first discovered for its role in
giving birth it's the the molecule
that's released from the mother's brain
when it's time to give birth and it
causes uterus contractions
and then after the baby is born the baby
begins to suckle to nurse
oxytocin is released to eject the milk
so the baby can get the the
milk to
thrive
but what we also know is that it's also
acting in the brain to focus the
attention of the mother to the baby
and to bond with that baby and to feel a
real sense of connection
and uh you know that was some of the
first
knowledge that we knew about oxytocin
and social behavior and then in in my
work we started working with these voles
these are little rodents they look like
hamsters
they're natural animals that live out in
the midwest united states and
uh there were two different kinds of
voles there was one called the prairie
bowl which is uh they live they have a
family life very similar to our our own
male and female come together they mate
after mating a transformation happens in
the brain and they form a bond
and then they they basically live in
that partnership for the rest of their
life they raise their offspring together
then the other species is uh a metal
vole they're solitary they're like those
trappers
they prefer to be by themselves and
and so we've been studying them to see
you know what is the chemistry of that
bond in the prairie bowls and
it turns out that oxytocin the same
molecule that's responsible for giving
birth is also helping to seal that bond
between these prairie bowls that bond
that lasts a lifetime
and oxytocin interacts with other
molecules like dopamine which is
involved in reward and pleasure in the
opiate system
and what we've kind of learned is that
you know a pair bond at least this
strong romantic bond
is is very much like an addiction
to a partner
but now we know oxytocin is also
really important for all
many other kinds of bonds you know bonds
between the dog
and the owner when a when your dog looks
at you in the eyes
it causes you to release oxytocin
and then want to nurture that dog
also just you know social touch you know
looking eye to eye contact causes
uh oxytocin release and
and what and it seems that what oxytocin
is really doing is separate is helping
tune the brain into the social stimuli
so that we
pay attention to that and can navigate
our social world
in the appropriate way
excellent well thanks for taking us
through i know a lot of people are going
to be just enlightened with that
information and
it's great to have that you know that
understanding again because it's come up
in so many different ways and pat as
someone who has you know expertise both
in neuroscience and in philosophy or
more appropriately in neurophilosophy
and he was also engaged in this how has
how has this information informed your
work and your conversations with people
around these aspects of bonding
well it's huge of course because
in in one respect it really constitutes
the platform
um for what we call morality but i want
to step back and and
because the sort of bonding that we see
in mammals and birds is really unique
um and
so you want to say well
because many people have been very
skeptical of the idea richard dawkins
actually is one
um that that there could be genuine
altruism that i could as it were
sacrifice something of my that i want
for the good of another
and and so the so so the idea is that
that could never evolve because if there
were altruistic individuals all these
selfish guys would take advantage and
poof that's that
so
so part of what really motivated me
after i learned about the bowls from
larry was
why would this happen why would there be
this kind of evolution
and i think the story actually goes way
way back about 200 million years
to the fact that warm bloodedness
appeared on the face of the
planet and um
the great thing about being warm blooded
is that you can forage at night all
those other guys have to wait for the
sun to come up
but you can forage at night but as with
with many sort of changes in evolution
there's a downside and the downside is
that gram for gram a warm-blooded animal
has to eat 10 times as much
now that's a huge evolutionary
constraint
as you know you can go off and leave
your lizard alone for a week and it
doesn't you know it's not going to be
starving when you get back it doesn't
need to eat that much
and also lizards and snakes don't take
care of their young they
they just have them and off they go
so what happened such that mothers and
in many cases fathers especially birds
do this amazing thing which is make this
enormous sacrifice for their offspring
and the answer is this that to meet this
ecological constraint of eating so much
getting so much energy
basically mother nature
invented the cortex
and that's a way of letting the animals
learn a huge amount about their
environment and
hence in a certain sense makes them
smart birds have cortex too it doesn't
look like it it's just a little
different from ours
so okay but if you're going to have
cortex
then what
uh it better not be already fully
developed it better be so immature that
the baby can learn from its environment
and that means the offspring are born
very very immature so then mother nature
has a problem well if they're that
immature they're not like a turtle that
can just come out of an egg and off they
go
a baby mouse can't do anything it's deaf
and blind and hairless
and we're pretty bad too
so you have to have some sort of
mechanism and this is what obviously
evolved in mammals and birds some sort
of mechanism whereby the thing that
gives birth is also the thing that
begins to take care of and oxytocin
although it was plentiful in the body
all over the place for hundreds of
millions of years
was put to a very new role
and that role had to do with bonding and
feeling good when you were with the baby
feeling bad when the babies were gone or
if they were being predated and so forth
so that i think you know it puts
morality into a completely different
perspective
from what most of the evolutionary
biologists had thought for so long
namely that
it has to be beaten into kids
no other animal has anything like it
because it goes against evolution and
the answer
is nuts
it is an evolutionary
development
so there's more of course to the story
but i like the fact that
something as
indirect shall we say as being
warm-blooded turns out to be
the essential part of the causal story
for the emergence of something like
attachment and bonding which is the
essential platform for morality
so much there and so many things that we
can pick apart too and one thing i'd
like to
just follow upon because we started to
talk about this developmental piece a
little bit already too so what are the
implications of that because you talked
about the young not having that
developed cortex yet and needing that
bonding so what are the implications of
that bonding happening early on for life
down the road and for each of you who
want to to jump into that
well i i'm just held forth so i'm going
to let larry uh start with that but i'll
talk about allison perky bile's work too
yeah so we've done some interesting work
in the in the voles that show that
if the if the uh the
pups experience a little bit of neglect
so they don't get as much licking and
grooming from their mother that licking
and grooming causes oxytocin release in
the brain
and if for the first two weeks of life
they get less of that
then when they grow up they actually
have a difficulty forming relationships
as adults
so uh you know this work suggests that
you know as an infant as the infant's
brain is developing
the kind of nurturing that it gets from
the parents the eye to eye contact the
you know the
talking about the
touching all of that stuff is re causing
a series of chemical events in the brain
such as the release of oxytocin
that's help constructing the circuitry
that determines how that individual is
going to be able to relate to others
later in life and i think that that's a
a huge it has huge societal implications
because before you know knowing this
kind of research you know people just
think well the baby is born they're
going to develop however yeah but they
really their future child
your adult child really depends on
how you nurture that child yeah
it's it's really really critical
i think that part of the story that we
haven't really touched on that's so
important here is
is the the other part of oxytocin and
that is the receptor on a neuron to
which the oxytocin binds
because what larry
and his cohort discovered was that it's
the density of oxytocin receptors in
very specific parts of the brain that
determines whether or not you're going
to be a long-term care bonder or not
and similarly you know we see that in in
some mammals there aren't uh male female
bonds that are super strong like in
baboons but what there are are mature
lines the the the head lady and her
daughters and her daughters and her
daughters and so forth
and so we can see that just by you know
these subtle alterations
of the pattern of where the oxytocin
receptors are
you get changes
so to follow up on on the developmental
point that larry was making alice and
perky bile showed that
when baby mice are taken from the mother
and for even just a few hours a day and
they're not licked or groomed but
they're fed and kept warm and then
they're put back
what you see is a lowering of the
density of receptors in the places where
you would expect it and like larry's
work with the voles what she found was
that
when those animals then become mothers
they are so to speak bad mothers they
don't really care that much they don't
bond much to their babies i mean they
don't have they don't have the mechanism
they don't have the receptors for the
oxytocin to latch onto
and so i agree with larry i think this
is just this is just super super
important i mean we all knew that it
wasn't very good to put those urani uh
those romanian orphans
in in cribs and leave them there for
years
but
um we understand
in a very direct way now
why it was so terrible yeah yeah and
that's so powerful i mean both what you
both mentioned just powerful having that
understanding of the brain mechanisms
and how
that impacts down the road go ahead
larry yeah i would just say you know we
did another study that's uh the first
study that i mentioned was about you
know neglect where the
pups were like sort of left alone for
three hours a day only three hours a day
that's not that i know it's amazing but
we also did experiments where they were
raised by
only the mom or the mom and the dad and
so in the case with only the mom the mom
had to forage for food and left the pups
alone in the nest for a certain amount
of time
or when they were both parents were
there they were always had a parent that
was uh engaged with the pups
even the pups that were that were raised
only by the mother with just one parent
they had more difficulty forming
relationships later in life so it is not
just you know at the extremes
um so i think the lesson is very
interesting um you know that it is the
um you know sort of the total amount of
nurturing that that that individuals get
that babies get whether it comes from
their grandmother
um from their aunt or from their father
or from the mother it's you know all of
that sort of accumulative kind of thing
and so you can think of it you know
babies this is a project that you're
working on to try to build a healthy
individual for the next um generation
you know yeah absolutely yeah i i that
is a beautiful experiment actually i
didn't know about that yeah yeah
definitely fascinating and for those who
who are listening who may be hearing a
lot of this the science for the first
time too i imagine
that it's both fascinating and
intimidating at the same time because
even as you're describing some of the
experiments that one perspective could
be well if that's happened does that
mean that that person is now
you know set to have disruptive
relationships going forward or are there
things that happen later on that can
also still have effects on the brain
when we talk about changes in the brain
and plasticity so how how do those
processes later on in life also
intersect
with some of these early
differences that you talked about
whether someone you know if we think
about humans if people have had neglect
in certain situations
is that something that are they stuck in
that category or what what happens down
the road
yeah no i don't think that they're stuck
in that category but they have that that
sort that trajectory and if that
trajectory isn't changed that trajectory
can change you know uh as they reach
adolescence or past adolescence or even
um you know as in adults
um
but it needs the attention to do that
you know they
someone
either that individual or someone needs
to say okay i
need to engage in things that would put
me in the right direction
so it's just as long as we're aware so
so even genes you know we often hear
genes
predict behavior but having a gene
doesn't mean that you have to engage in
that behavior that it predicts it's just
these are all just vectors that sort of
point people in certain directions and
if left alone they will continue to go
in that direction
but the knowledge that these are
directors that are pointing people in
directions and we know that that's not
the right direction
we should think of ways to change the
direction
because it means you know
health
and happiness all the way through life
you know we we live way past our
childhood
and
we don't want to you know if we had
difficulty in childhood we don't want to
be stuck
with the remnants of that difficulty we
want to fix those
yeah yeah
i sometimes think of those small
communities
of
hunter-gatherers or people like you know
small groups of inuit
maybe in you know
10 or 20 living in a small community
where
somebody's always there somebody's
always carrying the baby in in the hood
and
um and
i i do think city life makes things a
little more difficult shall we say
um you know we we don't always
know the people next door so we don't
always pitch in when we know that the
baby really needs uh
a certain amount of cuddling and care
yeah really well said
well i appreciate you know the context
that you've both put this in and with
the the the biology of it as well and
you know i think of both of you as
really excellent communicators and
excellent scientists scientific
communicators in terms of taking this
knowledge that we have and making sure
that it's part of the public discourse
would you say that in terms of i mean
everything that you both have described
and what we've learned about the
importance of these bonds are we really
paying attention to that enough as a
society or are there more things that we
should do because they even talked about
you know if those things happen early on
we can change the direction i'm
wondering even what are some of the ways
that we do change that trajectory
yeah i know i just asked two questions
at once but yeah i was thinking of the
first one well you know it depends on
the society because in many countries
like sweden you know they have
uh you know laws and policies that
really
uh
enhance the parental engagement you know
with paternal leave about uh you know
from work
and uh longer time uh
with the child so
um in this country we're lagged behind
some other countries but i think that we
are i mean slowly uh
gaining this understanding much more
than we were 20 40 60 years ago so we
are we are making improvements
and you know
as science goes forward you know this is
the business we're in science trying to
figure out you know how things work and
and how to make things better i think
that we are moving in the right
direction
just by appreciating the biology
think the other part of the story too
that that needs emphasis is that it
isn't just that the child needs to be
cuddled and so forth it also
especially in humans but also dogs and
and many kinds of species of mammals
the infants are
hugely disposed to imitate others adults
siblings and so forth
and how they learn
the norms of their group
is from watching and interacting and
doing things and being told yes yes
that's great or no you don't want to do
that and so forth and this is a part of
the story that engages a very ancient
system and that is the reward system
which is largely subcortical but of
course has
very dense interactions with cortex as
well
and so it's really important not only
that the children are loved and nurtured
but they also have the opportunities to
interact in social ways so that they
come to understand that on on the whole
truth telling is better than fibbing
and that that
disagreements can best be resolved
sometimes by working it out rather than
by bonking somebody on the noggin and so
on
but
but they need to pick these things up
and if they are raised in circumstances
that are really grim
they're going to pick up
very different kinds of norms
and and
and then it's going to be hard to undo
those
um and and
so so i think
that's a reason why family life and
extended family life are really very
important why grandparents have an
important role to play and
as well as siblings and aunts and uncles
and neighbors and and and dogs
so yeah
it is i mean dogs teach kids a lot um
and and that's
they're learning norms that that most of
us can't even articulate even now
but we know
we know
yeah that's so important and again it
seems that there's just a lot of uh
bonus
on each
member of the family in the community in
so many different ways i mean i wonder
also just from a philosophical
perspective
what does that say about us as humans
and the importance
of altruism
i mean as we have learned about all
these different all these different
outcomes and effects that these
interactions gonna have on our fellow
human beings what responsibility would
you say that
that has for us as fellow humans
well i think you know we even in small
hunter-gatherer groups people understand
in a very deep way the importance of
cooperation and mutual defense and and
so forth
and um and and i think that children are
very quick to pick to pick that up we
also see in cross-species
uh alliances for example between wolves
and humans or between wolves and galata
baboons
that there can be very close
relationships because they cooperate
with each other
and and that's really valuable in the
case of the of of us and the baboons the
wolves are very important in helping to
drive off predators
um and in return uh the baboons tolerate
them they they don't snuggle with them
in the way we snuggle with dogs but
maybe it took us a few generations as
well i don't know
well yeah i think one of the interesting
things about altruism is that we've
learned from well
and work with animals but also in in
humans is that
uh
we tend to think of individual others in
our species as either within our group
or out group yeah and so we exhibit
altruistic behavior towards those that
are in our group
and altruistic behavior is you know
someone is needs help and you help them
you detect that they need the help and
then you help them
and i think that evolved from the brain
mechanisms of maternal behavior because
mothers are always altruistic
they can see their hear their pup being
in distress or their baby or they can a
wildebeest can see their their baby
being approached by a lion and then
they'll risk their life to help that
their baby but i think in humans that
same the same neurobiological processes
have been expanded to others in our
group
because when we help our group our group
does better
the problem is who do we see as in our
group and who do we see outside of our
group
and uh you know i think that that
you know those divisions of who's who's
us and who's not i mean you can see it
in politics right now
us and them
and um yeah so that kind of division was
something that we really need to grapple
with how to
erase those boundaries
and sort of
you know so that the group
uh becomes you know all of us
yeah
yeah and increasingly i think you know
people
people are recognizing that
because the planet isn't an infinitely
large place and because uh things like
climate affect us all
that we do need to cooperate with people
that we don't know and maybe never see
and so forth nevertheless i think the
strongest i think this is almost
certainly to remain the case but the
strongest
uh desire for
health and reaching out and so forth is
going to be local
um i mean there is a group of
philosophers who say that's wrong that
it should always be you know the person
who's most needy wherever they are on
the planet but you know and like i have
this friend who's who cuts people's hair
i mean she's a hairdresser i guess
and
a couple of times a month she takes her
tools in the chair and goes down and
cuts the hair of homeless people now
maybe they don't need her time as much
as somebody else on the other side of
the planet
but
i think it's asking too much
to ask her you know to figure out who
really needs her help and to quit
running downtown to help the you know to
cut the hair of the homeless people
on the other hand where i absolutely
agree with with larry is that
we don't want to let localness
kind of be the enemy of
looking further afield when it's really
important to do so
and
so we have to both
you know be
motivated as we all are when it's
somebody we know
but we also don't want to have the
the sort of in-group thing where we're
the good guys and they're the bad guys
that's when the trouble starts yeah yeah
so many important pieces there and i
love how you've tied in that aspect of
altruism and just what the scientists
showed us about you know the within
group versus without group um so many
you know so many directions i could go
and i'm
formulating the ideas as i talk through
this so bear with me as we go through it
but i mean that's just something that
we've thought a lot about on this
podcast as well as we've talked about
aspects of social justice and then even
larry as you were talking it reminded me
of those components to thinking who is
within the group and who's outside and
the benefits of helping those within our
group but also on the flip side the
detriments of things that happen within
the group so i've referenced a couple of
times some of david williams work at
harvard looking specifically at black
and brown communities and the long-term
detrimental mental health effects when
there are individuals in those
communities who are killed at the hands
of police when they're unarmed and so
the way it it
goes both ways and so even as we're
talking about this just makes me think
and not you know not that there's
evidence for this per se but the power
of expanding
those groups
and what that would do for us
collectively as a society and whether
there would be some of these aspects of
the bonding that would happen from
biological practice that would have
long-term effects even in adults even
though we're past yeah yeah no i agree i
mean and there is some work on
chimpanzees
who um where they're the the field
observers were watching two groups
because they were both getting rather
large and they rather suspected that
there was going to be a bit of a of a
fight eventually which which there was
but they managed to collect urine
samples from
from
the members of the group before and
after the
incident
the oxytocin levels had gone through the
roof
these guys were they were all of a
sudden so bonded to each other and also
probably i mean larry could speak to
this better than i their stress levels
had gone down
um and so they weren't quite as afraid
and boy did they go at it
and that's very biological now are are
humans like that it would surprise me if
we didn't see it for example in football
teams
or base basketball teams maybe
baseball's too slow for it but um
yeah you certainly do you uh with uh if
you give someone oxytocin and you tell
them that these people are on your team
uh you're more likely to do something
altruistic to them
and uh maybe be more defensive to
someone who is told you are told is not
on your team and so you know i think
that um
it's a big deal it's it's a very it's a
very difficult thing
in terms of you know racism in the
society and to fix it right away
um
it's not it's not going to be an instant
fix of course um but you know if by
thinking about this you know this the
biology of responding to in groups and
out groups you know what we need to do
is to try to
you know think of ways move forward in
ways so that
race is not um our skin color is not a
factor to determine in group versus out
group
and and that you know can be done you
know through uh you know making sure
that
diversity is represented in all aspects
of our lives so we can see you know
whatever we are doing
uh
there's a lot of
different kinds of people that are also
like that you know and rather than
yeah
and it just takes time to reach
everybody yeah
in that kind of way
yeah
i think that's probably true i mean i
would love for it for these things to
move faster but
but i'm always gratified when you know i
see how for example sportscasters and
newscasters and in general how
it used to be you know your basic white
male
and and now
there's women there's people of color
there's you know all kinds and
um
and
because people watch television so much
i i have
i i mean maybe i'm just being
foolishly optimistic but i think those
things matter
and i think it is making a difference
but um
we've got a long way to go yeah yeah
i appreciate the way that you both
framed that as well and then even as
we've been talking you know thinking
back to some of the earlier comments
that we had in the conversation too it
also makes me wonder and this is getting
a little speculative but just about
those bonds early in life too
earlier if there are windows of
opportunity to expand
that circle in a sense like you were
talking about larry so that bonds formed
earlier and that there's less of this
we
and them us and them kind of framework
from early on and whether you know from
a biological perspective whether that
would also have long-term
effects
as people become adults and again i'm
speculating but just as we're having
this conversation and thinking through
some of those
those topics as well
yeah i think so i mean there was some
work done in rats though where they you
have uh
rats that have the different patterns
of fur
and uh if if they're raised with uh
other rats that have that have a
different color pattern of fur
then they were more likely to show
helpful behavior
to them so it does
yeah you know learning early learning is
important i think so um and so you know
i think just this is just something that
we as a society
have to recognize is important and just
pay attention to that and
uh increase uh you know exposure to
uh all kinds of people and um
um so that you know the the skin color
and all of these things are not
nationality or ethnic background are not
the division the divisors of
of groups
yeah um
yeah i know i i remember when i was in
first grade in school again this is this
tiny little school in in british
columbia and there was an influx of kids
who wore leather pants that were cut off
above the knees
and uh and of course what had happened
was that there were
a number of germans who were moved to
this area
to farm and start a new life after the
war
and uh we were all absolutely fascinated
by this and of course by the fact that
they didn't talk like us but you know
when you're only six these things don't
matter very much
so within you know
i don't know six months or whatever it
was all kind of they were still wearing
their leather pants because i think they
couldn't afford other pants but
but it didn't matter anymore and kids
are much more easy about these things
than adults
where you know we're kind of uh
ossified a little bit i suppose you'd
say yeah yeah and again i'm sure that
ties back to the biology as well
i think
i think the learning so
less that we could learn learn from uh
the younger ones among us as well yeah
so as we wrap up i know i was also just
going to ask a little bit about you know
some of the biology that we've been
touching on but of um consolation
behavior and then you know in this mode
that we're in of kind of the ups and
downs of the pandemic
what that has also meant for us as there
haven't been is the same types of ways
to express that consultatory behavior
and if there are ways that that can also
inform how we interact moving forward
because larry as you mentioned this is
not something that's going to be gone
anytime soon so
um but i guess we could start with you
as you study some of that as well
yeah i mean i think you know so so you
mentioned consolation that this is a
something that we studied in the voles
where we see that
if an animal's partner is distressed or
someone they know is distressed they
they release the oxytocin and it makes
them be tuned in to that partner and
recognize that they're distressed and
then do something
and uh you know i think that that we're
designed we're organized in such a way
that you know we detect others when
they're in distress and
have some urge to help them
and maybe we you know we don't do that
as much you know when we're isolated and
things like that but i think just being
aware you know that this is something
that we should do you know we
you know that doing that
you know it's the right thing to do
someone recognize when someone is in
distress you know it's also hard for us
to know
when people are in distress we see them
once in a while on zoom we don't know
what's going on when they're you know
alone and just to kind of be aware of
you know ask people how are you doing
and and reach out to them to
to help if
if they need help you know
anything you want to add add to that as
well
well i i was just thinking of other
species you know there's wonderful data
that france of all has uh of uh
chimpanzees
uh
consoling other chimpanzees and uh in
the wild as well as as in captivity but
of course dogs are incredible in that
way too
you know if you're upset or you're
tearful or
you've fallen or
the dog will come and they'll nuzzle and
they'll lick and if it's a baby i mean
you know they're
and
this used to be just waived off his
anecdotes
but but now there's
it's
there's so much real data as well as
lots and lots of anecdotes on on youtube
it's hard to
dismiss you know i think one thing
that's happened during this epi uh
pandemic is that people have realized
how
much of a lifeline that their pets are
yes you know absolutely uh because you
know they really have bonded even more
strongly with their pets and their pets
are a source of joy yeah that's really
social interaction that's oh
as others and so you know that's
something we we sort of in the absence
of other interactions we sort of
uh built and strengthened that
and that can help improve you know
mental health
um but but i do think that people need
to
um eventually
need to
um
wean themselves off of only that
because having real human social
interactions yes is so important for so
many other
things
so
yeah yeah one thing i've often wondered
and i doubt there's any way that
anyone's looked at this yet it's just
you know some of the things that you've
talked about in terms of the oxytocin
being being released in certain
interactions and how they can also build
trust whether that can also happen on
zoom if it happens to lesser
oh yeah yeah that's a big deal i don't
know if you've been talking about that
specifically or
yeah yeah that is a big deal people have
been talking about that since you know
before zoom before the pandemic as
people started texting you know
so um
children who hear their uh
are with their mother and hear their
mother's voice or their father you know
engaging with them they have a big peak
of oxytocin yeah but if you get a text
you don't yeah and i i'm sure that the
that the oxytocin release that you get i
mean even if you're just interacting
with another person and it's a positive
interaction the eye to eye contact is
causing oxytocin release
and that's like it's kind of like
exercising your social brain yeah you
need that from a day-to-day basis and
when you only get the interactions
through zoom
i don't think you're having that same
kind of interactions you don't feel the
connections you're a 2d
2d image that moves
and um
yeah so that's having long-term
impacts on me
there's an additional thing here which
is that oxytocin has what is sometimes
referred to as a sibling
peptide which is vasopressin
and sometimes uh
the release of vasopressin
can have to do with you know being
careful anxiety
uh caution and so forth and it turns out
that
this is work by sue carter that that
oxytocin can bind to vasopressin
receptors with the upshot that there can
be yeah well you know
yes but maybe not
and when i first read her paper i
thought about some of the male female
encounters one has especially for
example as a teenager you know is he
really being mean or is that a joke or i
kind of like him but maybe not and but i
think those sorts of complex dynamics
those ambiguities are often in play
even when we are contemplating helping
someone or
wondering whether we should you know
give them shelter and so forth is it
yeah yeah i mean
you have to be vigilant on who you help
you have to be
there's interesting work on rats you
know showing that uh an adult rat if
they're uh
have a choice to interact with a
juvenile rat that's in distress versus
another adult male that's in distress
they avoid that adult male that's in
distress you know
if they help that that's interesting
because an adult who is in distress uh
could be yeah
yeah and that is also regulated by
oxytocin
and
and vasopressin then they're yeah
these brain mechanisms so yeah how many
of the things that we you know that we
engage in every day that we don't even
think about what's going on in the brain
right yeah we're starting to understand
the hormones the chemicals in the brain
that's doing it but also now the
circuitry we're learning more and more
about the circuitry of how it's working
um and how the consequences of that are
accumulating over years to change our
behavior
and i think that the real you know what
i'm really excited about of the future
of this area of research um
you know is that
there are a lot of psychiatric
situations psychiatric disorders the
depression where people are withdrawn
socially
there's also autism or schizophrenia
and other areas psychiatric disorders
where people are just
you know resistant to interacting with
socially
or incapable
that what we've been learning through
these animals and with this oxytocin
system is how we might be able to tweak
the brain circuitry
and tweak these neurochemicals
so that we can help improve
the social outcome
of these disorders
and that's really the reason why i'm
doing the work that i'm doing yeah
is to try to you know to help us have a
better you know social navigate the
social world in a better way
yeah
awesome that's so exciting and so
encouraging a lot of ways especially as
you mentioned because it touches on so
many different yeah mental health
challenges and psychiatric illnesses
really is
key to how we interact on on a
day-to-day basis oh yeah
and so complicated
um
yeah
i think a lot of ways the listeners will
really enjoy listening to this episode
too and just maybe even self-evaluating
as you've shared so many anecdotes just
thinking about you know our daily
interactions because i mean you know
even as we were talking about the
difference between zoom and in person i
mean i'm thinking you know during
certain times during the pandemic just
going to the grocery store and making
eye contact with a stranger and how
elevating and encouraging that felt and
could kind of lift yeah you know lift me
through the rest of the day as opposed
to talking with people i knew really
well just by zoom so
yeah there's a lot there's a lot there
and a lot that we're still learning
moving forward
as a closing question one of the things
that give you all hope as we
move forward in our world with all that
you know about social bonding and then
also as we think about how we continue
to navigate um the pandemic uh pat i
guess we can start with you this one
well
i think in lots of ways people have uh
really pulled together and been very
sensible and and tried to do the best
they can
i think there have been many regrettable
things uh as as we all know
but um
uh you know
there are these kind of intervals where
humans fill us with despair
and then you know time moves on and and
the despair changes to optimism and hope
and so forth and i mean maybe this is
just an old lady speaking but but uh
i i i remain very hopeful about the
future and and about how people will
work together to solve certain kinds of
problems even even though maybe at the
moment
um we wish that there was more
cooperation than last sort of thing
calling
yeah
yeah i think in the last couple years
you know our world has really been
shaken up mine was shaken up you know
with the politics and with covert and
just uh you know thinking about what the
future holds and
and so yeah i think it's there was a
depth uh you know in a deep spot and um
that's why i sort of i changed my life
you know it's become trying to be
healthy i lost like 40 pounds and i
thought you did yeah yeah so uh i think
that we're going to do the same thing as
a society you know we're going to look
back you know it's not just covered it
was it's political yeah yeah
social injustice issues and all these
things
was really turmoil okay but
we're going to get through this pretty
soon it's going to be three years later
four years later five ten years later
we're going to look back at that and
we're going to say that was a changing
point
and also you know in terms of the
science we're going to think about the
things that we
know and
there have been a lot of changes in
terms of um you know social justice and
uh attention to diversity and i think
that have been happening
um i think that's going to continue and
i you know i think i just like i'm an
optimist so i like to to see things that
have happened that were really bad
in a positive light because they're
creating positive change and i think
they do actually and and sometimes you
just have to go through this sort of
dark night of the soul to come out at
the other end and really good things
will happen
so
yeah
world war ii into baby boomers you know
yeah you know
who knew
opportunity in a lot of ways i think i
think yeah
we'll definitely appreciate both of you
being here again i think this is going
to be so uh enlightening for a lot of
folks and encouraging
to listen to the insights that you
shared and you know just the fascinating
research and all the different angles
and nuances and i think just also you
know just to have a better understanding
of how some of the animal models and
what we can learn from the animal
kingdom about how
we interact as humans as well and then
just thinking developmentally so
grateful to both of you for taking time
out of your schedules your busy
schedules i'm impressed by both of your
exercise routines by the way so that's
something that is going to have to
encourage me to turn into action
hopefully yeah yeah actually exercise
raises the level of oxytocin there you
go it'll feel good yeah yeah so that
could be not at first but
yes well sad
okay yeah thanks so much to both of you
for being on the addie hour definitely
appreciate your time and all the
insights that you shared
[Music]